[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
20 international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
comm presents the second annual winter
chess classic welcome back to st. Louis
you are looking live at two of the most
important games thus far in this event
on your upper left
Jeffrey Zhang in his game against SAS
akhirin Jeffrey is undefeated can he
stay that way after round three in your
lower right well the man we're talking
about Lucas man forest away from the
board a perfect - an O in Group B today
he is playing zabun and ricean so we
will see what those games hold come on
into the studio and join us for a while
hello chess fans Ben Simon here along
with Grandmaster in residence Jessie cry
Jessie you have an amazing looking
mousepad today I have to compliment you
some people might think this is heresy
but uh I'm using fabi's nose and
moustache as my mousepad today well we
are only two days away from the World
Chess Champion right so what better way
to whet our appetites than with this
winter chess class if you know that's
right opening ceremony tomorrow it's
gonna be crazy awesome and I would say
just on the face of it this is the most
exciting round so far a lot of not only
fighting hymns but very interesting
games very hard to judge you know how
you what you think is going on in the
position yeah we're gonna be in for a
lot of fun today but let's see where we
are coming into this round here's the
standings for group a after two rounds
okay Jeffrey Zhang clear lead two points
we knew coming into this event to look
for we were looking at the youngsters we
were looking at maybe Ray Robson and
Jeffrey and Jeffrey has emerged as the
clear score despite the positions on the
left he is above it all two points what
are your thoughts thus far in this field
Jeffrey like we said yesterday
definitely has a chance to run away with
it and
his plan probably you know his biggest
threat in saucey today and it's a very
interesting game I like his position a
little bit better and we're gonna take a
look at that what else
the other thing jumps out to me is our
two other Americans ropes in Savion
aren't doing so hot and ropes in
especially right now he's playing kind
of on the wild side and I don't I can't
promise anything we're gonna take a look
at that game too it looks like that
could go either way
and as far as group B goes we have a
similar situation where we have a clear
leader Lukas van forest played his
countryman and friend Robby Camilla
yesterday he got the victory he's two
for two man forest a part of this big
dynasty of chess players going back five
generations and there's a slight
connection with that here today but what
are your thoughts on this field so far
Jesse well the big game of the day is
van forest against Andrea's Ian and it
is a slugfest
I'm not sure who is better it could go
either way the game I think has shifted
already back and forth so a big game for
deciding what's going on in the
tournament today there and then of
course always in Group B I'm into the
old guys I'm into my friend Eugene peril
Stein having a good event he's having he
has a rough position today my friend
Joel Benjamin he just suffered a senior
moment so I think he's on the wrong side
of a bad position and Viktor has a very
promising position against our skydiver
but our skydiver is a tricky guy and he
can jump out of the plane at any moment
he could he could yeah and you know I
know you're keeping a close eye on this
B group just as a template for your
future because you're canvassing door to
door for maybe a future slot here in
Group B at a classic everybody I talked
to here I say invite me it's not
unlikely I'm a good player but I just
want to play you know there we go that's
my that's my spiel here's what we're
dealing with here with our tournament
format we're looking at 210 player round
robins the time control is classical
ninety minutes for the first forty moves
and then thirty minutes added on
for the remainder of the game there is a
30-second increment from move number one
so notation is always required and
players may not agree to a draw before
blacks thirtieth move has been played
and that's to encourage fighting chess
here's the schedule for the next week or
so here in st. Louis the rounds begin
every day at 1:00 p.m. except for the
last day we are on the air with you two
and a half hours afterward at us chess
champs calm to catch the ends of the
games and really see how the rounds
break down get a lot of interviews it's
always a lot of fun the last day does
start early because of a potential of
playoffs that we will not have a tied
first place spot here when the players
leave st. Louis there must be an
undisputed king in a and B okay so let's
see what's going on today
here are the pairings for Group A and
you can see the games at us chess champs
calm you neski casada vs. Miro Sam
Sabean versus Alexander Schmemann off
Alexander multi lover TSA's rock milk
Quyen Rhea Robson vs. daro spirits and
as we've already stated our key matchup
first time ever
Jeffrey Zhang vs. Krishna and SAS
akhirin so Jessie let's take a glance at
that game and see where we are right
this kind of a story of this game has
been who can control whose pieces and if
you look at it it's a very typical
Grunfeld structure where White has more
pawns in the center and is hoping to use
those parts to dominate the black pieces
but as you see like most of black's
pieces are fine except this curious
looking rook on c7 and most of whites
pieces are fine except this night on b3
so the story of the game for several
moves now and I think even going forward
is who can fix their bad pieces and rook
c7 is a very odd that's what saucy just
put it is a very odd place for the rook
because it's in line with the bishop so
no e takes D for a while here
yeah so let's actually back step a
little bit and look how this happened
this was a very it's a line that many
players like against the Greenfeld
and the reason you like it is that
instead of having to play E for you play
III and you get this very solid buttress
against the bishop on g7
okay so groennfell players though aren't
especially afraid of it and there's many
different ways that black could have
played here but this is what we get and
there's the beginning of the bad rook on
b7 he's gonna have to figure his stuff
out and you see as well the night on e 2
he has to figure some kind of way to be
useful in the game each six was a
strange move to me but okay he's gonna
try to castle a four and c6 now let me
just explain so I don't know if Essex
was necessary but you just don't want to
lose the pawn to the bishop when you
castle
and c6 looks kind of strange too but he
didn't want flee b5 to happen to go into
the endgame at some point alright so
castles castles rook f d1 now I want to
say it's very hard in these positions to
know where to put your pieces because
it's it's not you have a very solid
position but it's not clear exactly
where you want to go so there keV eight
Knight see one now one compliment I want
to give Geoffrey is that he's obviously
a very good calculator and you know when
you talk to the old guys like myself who
didn't grow up in the computer
generation we have certain prejudices
against the kids of today and one of
those is they sometimes don't feel
they're bad pieces they don't feel the
necessity to improve
and here you can see Jeffrey really
understands that the night has to do
something
and each day it needs to find a job
right and so that we get Queen h5 now
tonight with the Queen was gonna push
the night away anyway alright so let's
look Queen age five
Bishop g3 notice to just how nice the
bishop on g3 is for controlling the any
kind of counter play against the White
King be five normal night be three queen
g4 and here you know big decision one of
the interesting things about the
position is that the knight made the
Queen move from a five so that this is
possible so I'm sure a five was one of
the moves that Jeffery considered
instead he plays rook a b1 and I want to
point out what this does is creates the
threat of Knight a5 it wouldn't be the
end of the world if black were to have
this but it would allow the knight to
relocate and fix himself right right so
as a response saw see plays rook c7 and
getting the game position and as we said
before it's a little funny because the
bishop on g3 but you can see his game
plan black is saying as long as the
knight is poor cannot do anything
effective then at least I shouldn't lose
this game that's I think the way he's
thinking about the position now a lot of
moves for white to consider h3 a5 and
something I'll stress is that it's hard
to know exactly what to do in these
positions because you definitely want to
fix your knight you need a plan for
where that Knight is actually gonna go
right well Jesse what is the drawback to
it means so taking the Knight to a5
taking it to D to e to hope to see for
sure yeah notice if it's not it's
definitely improvement if you get to c4
by the way let me just say something
kind of obvious the nighttime b3 is
being dominated by his pawn amis
right that's why I can't move anywhere
and so c4 would definitely be a reason
to invest two tempos in something right
though even then you're not really you
don't really want to take on e5 you
might want to sink your knight on d6
that might be a worthy endeavor if you
can get that but yes 92 lots of
candidate who's here for black / white
right and and Jeffrey is definitely
thinking about it um let me just say
something else that we've seen with
Jeffrey he's again ahead on the clock
he's got 15 minutes and with 19 moves to
go before move 40 it's a big deal so
that's one of the reasons I think
they're actually very much we saw in
both games that the time pressure of his
opponents helped one of the main reasons
he's leading the tournament right now I
see a lot of the younger players running
to time trouble a lot and it's notable
that Jeffrey is not one of them so you
know maybe that's maybe that's why he's
the way he is that's why he's so good
right let's jump over to Group B in the
meantime and take a look at our field in
that division
so in Group B the five games going on
right now at us chess champs calm Robbi
Cavaliere Lee versus Aram Jaco bien
Victor mikhalev ski vs. team or Gaurav
JJ a lemur Andy vs. Joel Benjamin
Nicholas theodoro vs. Eugene peril Stein
and our key matchup today in Group E is
going to be a tough challenge for Lukas
men forest as black as he takes on the
top seed in this group is Ivan
andreasson let's glance at the game yeah
so this has been a great struggle so far
and I have a feeling if you ask
different people what they feel about
this position you'd get different
opinion
white continues to have more space and
this bishop looks strong but on the
other hand there's always you know
potential for counter-attack and
encounter sacrifice with some kind of
Knight g4 at some point notice though
that at the moment neither Knight d5 is
possible nor Knight g4 because of Queen
g7 that's the problem
rights of 95o he's intending rook d1 and
it's kind of hard to bring another
defender on to g7 so this position is at
least at least compelling for black and
for white I mean there's problems that
when you're trying to do this and you're
trying to squeeze a guy there's always
the chance that your opponent's gonna
jump out and so rookie 5 I believe is
now the threat and you have to wonder
about rook d5 after that let's take a
walk through this game here I thought it
was been really interesting Bishop c4
and we get this kind of thing that's
very modern ie well I'm sure they played
this in the 1800s but I mean this is the
way people play chess nowadays I talked
to that force a little bit he is very
prepared in the opening and 97 the idea
is that the knight currently is
dominated by the pawn on c3 so he's
going to try to go to g6 white takes
this however this movement of 97 is his
cue to play d4 and change the structure
of the game now when I first saw this I
thought okay this isn't this is pretty
good for white but after Bishop d3
Bishop g4 I realized it's kind of
annoying so white has the space but now
after h3 Bishop h5 how do you intend to
deal with the pawn on d4 for example
rook e1 came now we go back as he sick
right the night is no longer dominated
on c6 because the bonds gone and he
wants that pawn to either take the pawn
on d4 or to make it move if he makes the
pawn on d4 move the bishop will be open
to f2 so G for Bishop g6 d5 and I
thought this was a very lovely position
for a van forest because all of his
pieces are going to be strong the white
player here though is looking to try to
use a space to keep black down I have to
keep him in his cage so 94 bishop b1
rook e8
a 396 d4 and here's the first move I
didn't quite understand event force he
played Knight b8 and I just wanted him
to do something either like c6 or c5 to
immediately try to make the knight on a
six useful right by hitting the pawn on
on you know if your c6 is gonna be a big
question of how you want to deal with it
and maybe my knight can come back then
to c7 it's funny so after a knight b8
though white is gonna begin a campaign
of trying to make that particular night
bad so Bishop b2 c6 now yeah why didn't
you do it before I didn't understand
Knight c4 snip snip snip now we get some
trades and this is we're now getting
close to the structure that we see in
the game and this will come down to time
pressure and white needs to find a way I
try to get rid of the arrows my feeds a
way to get rid of it to deal with the
rookie 5 threat sorry that looks like a
football diagram my arrows won't go
right click that black space besides the
decide the board will that take them off
no okay we'll figure that later
okay so now that we've taken a little
bit of a glance set both of our key
matchups there's a lot of fun games
going on today but before we get to that
let's just glance at our prize funds
these players are playing for money
$22,000 on the line with six grand going
to the a champion and in Group B it's
very generous as well fourteen thousand
dollars total prize fund and the
champion leaves with $4,000 want to
remind all of you to join us
not just at us chest champs calm but
we're also on Twitch we're on YouTube
you can go on to twitter and join the
conversation hashtag winter chess
classic and yes very dangerous I had I
do have the YouTube chat open right now
and if you have any questions coming
from up here well thought out send them
our way
and we will read them on the air okay so
Jesse you were really excited about some
of the games going on yeah what piques
your interest to start off first of all
before we jump to any others I want to
look back at the Jeffrey John game if we
pull that up on the board and what's
going on and I go where that we don't
get it yet what we have there is
remember when we left it it was Brooke
c7 and that was the big choice on the
board of what to do and white played a 5
ok in Jeffrey Zhang's game we able to
get that or hit that we'll get that on
the screen remember 8 wheels there we go
so we were having this interesting
question about what to do I liked your
plan intuition of Knight d2 c4 that made
sense to me but when we think about long
term it's also the case of course the
it's hard to choose right it's hard to
choose and the idea I think of a5 is
eventually I would like to take and put
my rook on a one where my rook will
hopefully be better
then his rook but of course I still have
to fix the night interestingly saucy
just said okay I'm just gonna play this
small move and ask you what you want to
do so this isn't a fortress by black but
it's something that feels similar to one
where he's just gonna sit all right he's
gonna sit on this and see if Geoffrey
can break him also when you have a
little bit of time pressure that's I
definitely think the way to play it yeah
so let's move on and a game that I'm
really interested in is this game with
moti left and brought mikuni on you know
moti left has played a couple white
openings notably in round one he won a
nice game against Nero with a very
similar slow build-up as white and it's
interesting because modal F you know is
became famous as an attacking player and
now he's playing these rather slow
positions that usually end in end games
so let's take a look and what he did
here is he stole the bishop and had this
very modest set up as white hoping that
the bishops will eventually be better
I love Malcolm Ian's next move a very
fighting move and I think I'm gonna say
you know no qu Mian often gets to train
with lavon and gets to plan the same
Olimpia team and this f5 move feels like
a Levon Aronian an inspired move where
you play you know the King got 288 for
free because we had a check on e7 so
this is a natural thing to do
unfortunately I feel like right around
here was his chance to play f4 which is
I think the dream of playing this
position and I think well let me just
show you what I think he was worried
about f4 Bishop h3 rook d8 and rookie
six it looks kind of like that's not
what you wanted to see because all that
this little light squares are weak but
I do believe that was his chance to
blacks chance to get an active game here
as it was 96 was played queen h5 Bishop
III and white traits off look at how
modal F is playing these days he just
wants a slow endgame and what I say here
is what modal ifs aiming for what he
eventually is going to get is what we
usually call the Fischer endgame with a
bishop and rook against rook and Knight
where the dream is to dominate the
opponent's rook and Knight simply
because the rook and Bishop Fisher
discovered this right can work that way
to dominate to dominate the rook and
Knight and let's take a look it takes a
lot of skill by the way to do this
notice the night is already poor and
this position definitely a little bit
better for white and right there we have
it this is the this is the Fisher
endgame King f2 King e6 rookie a check
so bronze has a difficult and game ahead
of him
and one thing that he might take comfort
in is at the very least this pawn on c4
isn't really where it wants to be
because it's blocking the bishop so
White's Bishop still needs to find a way
to become active and I'm guessing that
if I got inside her anse mind he was
that you'd be saying I don't think my
position but at least that Bishop isn't
a you know somewhere active yet I assume
though that at some point B 4 and C 5 is
gonna have to be White's dream maybe
even at some point sacrifice the pawn to
c5 because black might try to shut it
down if you do play d4 so very
interesting endgame ahead of us there
both players of course heading into time
well it you know they're close to 40 so
it won't be incredible time pressure
I've got to take a look at a game in
Group B I have no idea what's going on
there's been a crazy sacrifice in the
game between theodoro and peril Stein so
let's jump on over and try to wrap our
heads around this yeah this has been an
interesting game for a while and I've
been fearing as I said at the beginning
I've been fearing for my friend peril
Stein because it does not look good and
let's back up a little bit yeah see how
we got here
peril Stein is easy to prepare for like
most old men yes because he always plays
the same thing he's been doing the same
thing for years and years and years I I
was in the in the room when this
happened and the theodoro played c5
instantly and we got this kind of
interesting position I thought black was
fine I still believe black is fine here
rook e1 Bishop f5 95 and here's the
here's where the beginning of the
fireworks start the issue here is white
both white has a problem and black has a
problem
White's problem is that that pawn is
going to be under attack and blacks
problem is that the Queen on a6 is
unhappy she's worried about a later
Bishop f1 at some point ruining her day
right so now basically all the tactics
that start now have to do with those two
things 97 happens and here we go here's
the drama
efore takes takes rook a da
okay takes and this was it the first
well there was already more than one big
decision here but this decision is one
where I feel like peril Stein
capitulated where he played Knight takes
g6 after which we have to say that black
structure is really compromised
especially along the light squares right
this one this diagonal this square all
of that is now open for white to come
and give and theodoro has some good
instincts coming up here where he's
going to say I'm no longer interested in
material I'm interested in putting your
King under stress and opening the
position for this bad boy here unopposed
light square bishop so Bishop III
I think c5 was controversial because
you're opening the Bishop d5 snip so we
say why did my friend Palestine plate c5
because he listened to too many yasser
sarah 1 videos and thought grubbing
pawns was a good thing it's distasteful
it is distasteful rook b1 okay so here
we got the situation queen a5 and here i
don't know if this is the best move but
the spirit of the move I really like
instead of snipping on b7 which I have
to imagine what's possible he said nope
I want to open it up I want to hunt your
pieces down Bishop f6 h 595 Bishop f4
and Knight c4 know the knight is
dreaming of what coming back to d6 and
maybe holding on so even though white is
down upon this is not what any player
wants the Queen is separated from her
man over here I just mean it's hard for
her to get back to the defense the rook
on b7 is very powerful
and the unopposed bishop means that at
some point this Bishop is going to come
and hurt us now I have a feeling that
upset with his position peril Stein now
played ePHI the natural move would have
been Knight d6 and I assume that the
reason he decided against this which is
I'm going to guess his original
intention was that after Bishop takes
let's just say pawn takes for fun Bishop
before the light squares are going to be
on fire right alright so but II 5 not a
happy sign and theodoro feels inspired
by this and says you know what let's see
if I can mate you now did he have to
play that way no he could have done
other things he could have played Bishop
h6 he could have played Bishop c1 so he
must believe that it's close to over
here but it's not immediate of course
it's a mess I don't know exactly what's
going on black has more than one move
here he can take he can play Knight d6
it's not totally clear to me what's
happening if okay so if the e pawn
captures the bishop how is Nicholas's
idea to capture on h7 with the bishop
check and then bring the Queen in and
fork the night in the King on d3 but
remember you're giving up two pieces
right yeah
it's it I don't know this looks a little
unsteady for white is there something
here for him I think there might be and
I think the dream is to put the Queen
here so let's just try out that dream
let's try it out
we're okay - all right check to the
misérable King if Bishop g7 let's play
Bishop g7 so now if h6 maybe I can
survive with some kind of queen a1 maybe
but let's try the obvious Queen f5 and
honestly that looks like game and that
looks like a bum deal notice that the
rook is helpful because in some
situations like this you can move your
king out so that on Queen h7 you have
King f8 but unfortunately if my friend
plays rook e8 BAM that's gonna happen
and then made on g7 yeah this is this is
not fun
okay so what can you gene do well with
so let's go back he did not take on e4
he played 96 sensible and check this out
Bishop b1 uh and now you need this is
the this is the game physician Eugene
can take on b7 he can take on f4 or he
can do something else now the good news
for Eugene is at least she has more time
now let's look at some of this stuff I
think the problem with EF is the same
thing rookie to but now unfortunately
the rook on a2 is protected right so the
problem you're gonna have to deal with
is what are you gonna do against the
coming queen g4 and f5 the knight note
though notice is at least covering that
so actually it's even Queen d3 now that
the bishop is back its queen d3 that's
the issue in fact you know maybe rook a
to isn't even necessary I just play
Queen d3 and say hello hello what's my
name
okay so EF 4 is out and for the same
reason Knight d7 is also out let's
double check that rook e8 and Queen h7
this isn't this requires some
calculation because something like this
he's escaping so let's take a look
Knight b7 this now I do like rook yeah
I'm okay too I like more now because
let's say Queen before or something I
give a check
and now after Bishop g7 actually it's
still kind of complicated
I was thinking obviously in King h8 it's
gonna work but here Queen f5 we're gonna
escape with the old method here this is
still a mess though you know it really
is ok this is fun I have a feeling
though that this is not that that he
should not take on b7 and I doubt he
will but then but let's just figure it
out so Knight takes b7 Queen D 3 and
then rook F e8
let's play Bishop h6
yeah I don't think you're gonna I don't
think he's gonna lift through it he's
down a rook but I don't think he's gonna
live through it so instead of Knight b7
this is what Eugene is pondering what
else should he do
whether this is sound or not I admire
how Theodora has played this notice for
example that if tried to just do the
old-fashioned block the bishop out then
I just sniped on d6 and taken the
LightSquared harassment you know starts
happening again notice to it that h4 h5
to get the knight out of g6 is part of
this thought that he must have had when
the bishops disappeared to say oh
especially now that you've took on g6
and there's not a pawn on g6 it's time
for me to really go after those light
squares so we'd have to ask yourself
what can you gene do that isn't taking
one of those pieces that helps us
somehow
get out of the way of all the terrible
things that are coming and it's not easy
I don't know it is beautiful right two
pieces are hanging and it's the light
squares you have a puzzled look on your
face though so there's so much to think
about it yes situation I'm having
trouble even formulating questions so
you're looking at one thing and then
it's that another pops up yeah yeah be
interesting to see what peril stone does
here this is a three result game
wouldn't you say oh well I honestly it
it it should be from a positional
standpoint it should be lost for black
it's obviously very tactical but from a
positional standpoint though light
squares are terrible and the Queen is
away from her man and that's the usual
recipe for just being lost yeah
well okay let's let's give it a little
bit and come back in this game let me
just say one thing at some point you
could imagine maybe doing like bishop
somewhere weird like g7 or h8 and
playing f5 that might be a way to fight
for the light squares okay yeah let's go
to a different game Victor metal web ski
Raz game as Y in Group E against team or
garea what is going on on the kingside
whoa this has been a squeeze game for a
while and one thing we might end up
criticizing Victor for is that he has
like every good man old man should do
he's been trading off stuff in his time
he's really low on time compared to T
morning
yeah and that's been the case for a
while so he's had the advantage the
entire time let's just notice some
obvious things
this night is terrible this night has
actually some interesting possibilities
for counter play this pawn is the one
that if it falls it's going to be really
dangerous so taking the Queen not really
an option I don't think because we have
both rook takes d6 and Knight c5 on the
table after that so the team er needs to
try to move I assume something like
Queen c7 now maybe he has some mother
you know he's trying to conjure up he's
trying to find a different way to jump
out of the airplane actually I take that
back he could take here and then
actually do this it looks ugly but I
can't take on c5 because the knight the
rook actually is also covered by the
knight in addition to the rook
d7 let me take this back a little bit I
was spending a lot of time with this
game I think a six is a normal move in
this position but I didn't really like
it and check out what Victor played here
g4 not the only move but really nice and
interesting move and I believe the
tactic that he's looking at is if this
then we're gonna snip and we're gonna
snip and we're gonna land on e8
because the night is not guarding it
right so very clever and the idea of g4
is very simple that I want your I want
to grab space on the Kings side and I
want to make the knight on f6 poor right
it's not in that sense it's not
complicated so he went back as he saw he
was gonna have to anyway g5 came to
dominate and Timur said I'm gonna put
all my faith in that battery on the long
diagonal here Victor started thinking
and it's hard in this position to you
know imagine to beat someone like team
or anybody at this level where you're
trying to squeeze them every move you
have to be exact every move and the next
couple moves I wasn't convinced of but
he it's true that Victor held the
advantage bishop g3 Knight f8b 391 I'm
just gonna point out and I'm not
thrilled about 91 because I don't feel
like we should be trading any of blacks
minor pieces because he's in the cramp
right now so I I wasn't happy with the
trade it's funny Timur even gave him the
chance to play e4 I think he should take
the chance and play e4 here but he
doesn't lazy for himself
white is definitely still better and
what a mess we have h5 Bishop a5 rook d3
we're getting 9a for Queen g2 team war
did take and like I said Bishop c7 so
Viktor has very little time but oh I'm
sorry this I'm sorry this I got confused
we're still on Queen g2 and team were
thinking about at least it would be
against team where's nature to take on G
to inflate the ship c7 but maybe the
other choice is also passive with Queen
c7 which also just doesn't look
appealing at all because none of your
pieces really makes sense would you
capture the Queen on g2 in this case
well it's really dangerous not to you
know well let's say it's dangerous both
ways because this is such a passive
position it would also be pretty easy
for Victor to play in time pressure in
fact if you just play h6 and then move
back and forth your shirt of main time
control and is having a nicer position
on the other hand if you play Queen c7
you have to worry about all kinds of
stuff including the Queen a 8 maybe 8
with h6 first and you know winning the
pawn on a 6 isn't just winning the pawn
the Queen will also be touching d6 so
it's like if the Queen comes in it might
end up looking like a pinball machine
down in there right thing
ding-ding-ding-ding hitting all your
stuff that's kind of the danger yeah all
right how about we check in with
Jeffries game sure Jeffries young and
sassy the marquee matchup in Group A how
he developed let's go to where we were
it was a 5 h 6o and we're gonna see
Geoffrey now is 16 minutes left and
saucy has three so we're fulfilling that
prophecy
ceefor committal move c5h three takes
takes d5 Queen d6 all right let's talk
about this for a second
the queen is not a great block hater and
furthermore she's also on this line that
is in the end of the world that they're
on that line because it's hard for white
to open up but it generally it it could
prove to be of tactical value later
almost certainly that the bishop makes
that pawn unsteady so finally we're
getting ready to fix our knight ready to
go to e4 and sassy says no you may not
fix your knight know about that for a
knight rook a1 now here's the first
example where the pins along this
diagonal are useful for us because we're
now able to play rook a one without
efore being a major drag for us King h7
kind of fulfilling the dream that he
started when he played h6 long ago just
sitting he just wanted to sit on this
position rook a six and now Queen f8 so
my sense is that this looks very
promising for Geoffrey from two angles
one for for him having the ability to
start a long term press and two now he
can take some time to craft a plan
whereas in whatever he comes up with
saucy is gonna have to react pretty
quickly to is there any reason to be
concerned I know that the Queen just
moved back yeah hey what about black
playing F for trapping or I guess the
bishop wouldn't be trapped is there any
concern there though there's definitely
concerned but bear in mind if you play
f4 you're gonna give my Knight to e4
square okay for life right so that's
something to be worried about but of
course you know we could be a little
afraid of it and one way if we wanted to
just be careful about it that wouldn't
be a bad move would be to play f3
but I'm sure what the Geoffrey's looking
at is a way to well a plan right and one
plan actually with f3 could be to play
e4 after that that's not a that's not a
bad notion at all there's a lot of
interesting ways sorry about the the
arrows I can't get rid of those little
buttons on the bottom does it oh great
out on a break or something okay we'll
figure it out anyways yeah so I like
this position a lot for Geoffrey and I
think f3 would be the the old man and me
would play heft 3 that's what the old
man in me would do because then you are
flexible and white black has to worry a
little bit about any kinds of ephors and
f4 is never a problem for you yeah so
very promising position but I think the
story is still the night on d2 how are
we going to get that night active and
yeah that's the creative struggle right
now for Geoffrey can we jump over to
group B I was like grouping let's look
at a game we haven't yet the Turkish 20
year 1 year 21 20 year old rather JJ Ali
Miranda taken on the three-time u.s.
champion Joel Benjamin at first glance
Benjamin's
pieces look disjointed yeah what's going
on
they've been disjointed for a long time
and I'm gonna show you
Benjamin senior moment here I'm allowed
to call it it's not making fun now
because I'm sure saying all these things
not me well though I've had my own
senior moment so I know what it is and I
know what it feels like and I'll show
you an example in this position which I
thought where I think Benjamin must have
been very happy with his position
there's a lot of different moves he
could play he gets aggressive and plays
b5
and 95 b4 and it looks on the surface
like he's done well however there is a
problem here and that is that he missed
the very cruel queen a6 and if you don't
well your Queens obviously under attack
okay and if you go back to d8 then I'm
gonna snip your pawn on c6 and the
game's over the Knights there for life
so takes happened and then this is a
very disruptive check King d8 first he
snips the bishop then he snips the Queen
and this position is close to lost
because the pawns the double pawns are
not so happy and that unopposed
light-square bishop is very strong
however I play Benjamin a lot of
positions kind of like this and to take
the old man down now kind of like where
where after my cholesky had his senior
moment yesterday he he still drew the
game and so we might still see that here
some of these moves by white maybe in
hindsight as as as Monday morning
quarterbacks we might decide they
weren't that good but in general White's
playing simple stuff right he's he's
fixing his rooks the pieces are active
and he just needs a way to fix the
knight in there it comes Knight F to h5
here loads of choices you can put your
knight back on g5 a lemur on D Drive
Bishop g5 very pleasant position for
white but you know Benjamin's tough to
beat and already here he's giving the
bishop to business and now he says not
only am I going to get your bishop but I
might get a little bit of counter play
so allowing this wasn't in white's plans
let's put it that way and now that we're
in time pressure maybe we can say that
anything could happen but I believe that
it still should be the case that white
is better
and this is our current position here so
Benjamin's done well to not lose
instantly right in this in this
situation yeah well and joel has two
minutes plus he a permit to make about
six news
right it does look like he played rook
hh7
yeah well oh right now first it was here
what do you want and then there we go
yeah yeah very pleasant for white very
pleasant but it's it's not over at all
not over at all can we look at my friend
Eugene and that beautiful sacrifice that
Theodore Oh played yeah let's go back
it's still Group B action here let's go
to where we were it was Bishop b1 and
Eugene fine so for this we decided that
no you cannot take the bishop you cannot
take the rook I don't know if the
computer would agree with us but that's
what at least my human judgment said and
Eugene said okay Lisa I'm gonna stop the
Queen from coming to either d3 or c2 to
hit the h7 square rook b 3 so that's
pleasant for white because now the rook
gets to relocate without loss of time
Queen C 4 and now another sacrifice rook
takes any fun oho I like the way this
kid plays I mean this is exciting chess
and not only that but well Eugene I
guess at this point says to himself if I
don't take the rook I'm simply lost it
so I might as well try to take it so
let's just talk about the intuition the
intuition is that all of whites pieces
are really ready to gang up on the black
King you have questions no I'm sorry in
this position and so it's it's not
something I feel like probably white is
calculated out to the end it's just a
feeling that all of these pieces are
work
I assume in this position that f6 will
come and another bonus that we get here
by taking on e5 is this pawn was in the
way of us trying to knock out the block
hater so in addition to talking to the
King side it's always good to attack the
defensive blockade square on d6
so let's think about this for a second
Black's Queen is gonna hope to be active
hope to not get caught in some kind of
catastrophe herself and the rook is
gonna hope to be able to somehow swing
over here also that rook does not ever
really want to trade himself off that
would be a bummer for white the position
on the board is now Bishop takes e5 I
was suggesting f6 maybe there's other
moves but well it's hard to imagine
another move besides f6 and the nice
thing about f6 is if I was in this
position I could at least dream of
surviving I think because the rooks
might be able to help laterally like
later I might be able to play a rook f7
to guard the pawn on h7 Eugene's got six
minutes this is going to be both players
are in big-time pressure they've got
almost like nine moves left
all right if I'm gonna talk to Eugene
later I'm gonna say Eugene why did you
just play it what you just play m6
directly buddy uh I don't know what else
he's supposed to do I do have a result
our first result right today yeah Ruby
perfect no more
Lucas van forest has drawn his game with
black against zhabin and Rihanna that's
our key matchup in Group B it's unusual
for someone to start 3 you know I think
much more so than to know so you know
you can't put undue pressure on him but
that is one of the games we were looking
at for standing purposes
yes that's kind of look to out how that
finished because I really this was
rookie 8 we were looking at this it's a
very unbalanced position Queen f3
hitting the night Queen e7y just crying
out trying to hold the position
there's moves here that both sides could
potentially complain about oh yeah
white ended up maybe getting a little
bit of something-something here but then
they just went back and forth probably a
fair result that the problem is is that
white has to babysit the pawn on d5
maybe there was some way for white to
play like Knight d4 here would be the
dream to try to play a 94 I think
actually the rookie 5 just happens and
then it's it's nothing special so a very
a draw but you know that was a very
hard-fought game let me just show the
position that I really thought was
interesting this one here oh I'd love to
be black in that one oh that's just fun
you know all your stuff is out in the
bishop's hitting f2
I want a sac on g4 oh by the way there
was another even here bishop g6 was a
fine move but he could have thought
about Knight takes d4 there right oh
that's except I would've oh I don't know
what to think about that one and Rios
Ian's back rank there and the last
position you showed with the bishop on
b1 right look like they were playing
Fischer random yeah
right but you know it's just anything
can happen
let's go to our key matchup Youth a
group a Jefferies young against sassy so
yeah let's give just an update on how
this happened so f right we did this and
that was our position
Jeffrey played Bishop h2 so
interestingly getting out of the way of
f4 and maybe there was some reason that
he didn't want to commit to the f3 move
that I was kind of fond of there maybe
I'll ask him after the game rook e8 okay
one
snip-snip queen c8 queen a3 White's
definitely better and you know what
what's funny about this is I said
earlier on I was like well the story of
blacks position is that bad rook and
kind of amazingly you know that rook has
been bad since move thirteen when it
took we took on v7 it's been bad since
then and here we are in this position
here with rook b7 and it's still bad
Queen 1/4 so black has to wonder about
Queen c6 and he makes a counter
sacrifice now let's call this a
defensive sacrifice to play b5
and what whether this is objectively
right or not
the spirit of the move I kind of like so
what this is going to do is make the
rook permanent the gives the rook
permanently a job because the pawn on d5
will always be in the rooks
sights and it gives the knight a square
on b6 and the night is going to be
looking at the d5 pawn and here's a
moment where I might want to have have
had my pawn on f3 so I could have played
efore but still this is a pleasant
position for white
Sassy's got one minute left Oh saucy one
minute left against the beast and
Geoffrey has several interesting moves
to consider here the most natural of
which would be e for he could also
consider excuse me the Queen's hang
that's important babies are like we day
two followed by well this is this is
interesting that what saucy did so
imagine if Queen a to I think saw C's
intention is to make a run for the
border with c4 not so nice that looks
pretty bad actually right and and notice
now this pawn is no longer pinned to
anything so he can at some point think
of e4 and that would make it so this
pawn a c3 would really be invulnerable
right once it got there so that's
frightening
so let's rule so oh this is an
interesting thing one notion maybe could
be something like Queen a3
looks unnatural but at least after this
we could harass with Queen d6 also
complicated there's a lot going on here
well what I mean what if the pawn pushes
to c3 yeah
and they let's say b3 don't get me wrong
I'm scared I'm scared
hmm let me complain now this will just
later since my complaint will be shown
to be superficial I will I will own it
but I just want to complain a little bit
I didn't like Bishop h2 and it creates
some of the problems that we then get
because now the King doesn't have a
flight Square and it makes it easier for
black later to play e4 makes it harder
for us to play e4 so that's that's gonna
be my complaint
Jesse I'd like to take a look at another
game here there's a lot of stuff
breaking down here at the same time ray
Robson vs. Darrow spirits oh yeah this
lady here for Webster and slue
respectively this has been interesting
for a while oh man so like I said before
I really felt when I looked at a lot of
Ray's moves ok live position 12 moves
left to play and both players have this
time alright alright alright yeah this
was a death wish the lot of the ways
that Ray played in this game it really
was Death Wish stuff it start I'm gonna
do a couple moves just show come was
then we're gonna come back yeah he
played b3 on move - I thought he
actually got a reasonable position and
then here instead of playing the natural
like Knight h3 is like let's play Knight
c3 and then start doing this whole dance
oh man things got hairy right away and
then right away of course you're gonna
think forever in a position like this
both sides are but in principle white at
Black has to be
oh I got all I got I have permanent
counterplay so we get all this mess
oh man and this is gonna develop
naturally to where we get in the game
you gotta like oh this is frightening f4
look at that look at that move boom
excuse me
boom I'm gonna open up my rook on f8 I
don't care how it happens if Knight f4
I'll play g5 and I'll just win the thing
Timur garea goes down oh nice Viktor
mikhalev ski it won't be action there we
see the resignation - you know Timur
he's only played two games because he
missed the first round had to forfeit
that and you gotta wonder getting off to
a start like that where you missed the
first round maybe you come in a little
bit jet-lagged maybe a lot jet lag what
this tournament is gonna have in store
for him maybe we can see him rebound
down the road and if I could I would
like to put a request out there to get
an interview with big Mick if we could I
thought he played a very interesting
game because several positions I'd like
to talk about the former Group B
champion indeed yeah let's see if we can
get him down here also elsewhere in
Group B JJ a lemur on D with white has
secured his win against Joel Benjamin so
those those results came an off week
awfully clipped quickly for Group B but
let's OH
and Quesada in Group A has drawn his
game with mural right so as to be
expected rapid fire can we go back to
the Ray game I let yes let's do it
please so let me just show you what
happens here spirits is putting on a
show and when you play deathless chest
like ropes and did that's what you're
gonna get rook f4 what's the problem if
EF that's mate Oh brutal mate so he said
nope I'm not having any of it but now I
think well it's hard to imagine it's not
lost and and let's look at how this went
down it went so wait wait wait check to
the miserable King can't comes up a be
very nice
a be checked the miserable King efore
has to be played and now the rook on f4
is a permanent invader the guys that
going anywhere let's just say blacks
winning I don't know how he should
finish it but this is over
rook f3 should be winning all kinds of
moves should be winning here
he played Queen h3y a simple chess
this is toast yeah real bummer for Rey I
you know I feel like he had some rough
breaks at the beginning and this loss
you know he's so solid it's hard to call
a loss psychological like I lose the
psychological things like I feel like I
deserved more and then I play crazy or
something but that's what it feels like
it feels like he's he was on tilt like
the poker players play we're saying is
on till okay
so there's all kinds of games to look at
let me just peek in at a very important
game board our standings modal F and
milk ooh Mian and modal s giving him the
business it's not over but this is
definitely Fischer endgame territory
this pawn might become weak at some
point and the knight has difficulty
moving the dream though at the moment of
Malcolm Ian's with an item c8 is to at
least contain that rook on a a and again
we're still trying to contain the Bishop
on d3 and the the fact that this policy
is here on c4 is one of blacks only
hopes now to say that the bishop is a
little bit bad let's look at how the
game with Joel finish up yeah so when we
left it we had it was a timestress
struggle we had rook hh7 and here comes
a nice opening of the position f4 rook
EG 7 oh I have it I don't know quite but
I would have guessed there's there must
be some problem with that move
some reason why that move doesn't work
maybe I don't know that would have been
the natural move there's problems all
around like f5 is also coming
Jessie while you ponder this game we do
have victor down here for a greater view
so i will be back in just a just a
minute alright while we're waiting for
victor let's just look at this if rook
EG 7 has to be played things are
obviously not looking good
9h 3 the night finally improves oh yeah
this is not pleasant things went
downhill very fast the night's coming to
f4 and black says enough notice that the
night on b6 really has been marginalized
and not only is black down a point but
night a force coming and these pawns are
gonna go so a very sad game for Benjamin
I'm sorry to see it I liked his opening
but Queen a6 that's the kind of move
that the old guys will miss speaking
from experience
let's check in while we're waiting -
with peril Stein and here we got big
Nick coming in very nice game big Nick
come have a seat
we're looking at peril Stein's game he's
in a rough situation actually while we
while we have you here
what is your just first take on this
position here with with Eugene
yeah I don't see oh yeah there's a
pretty good up there it is right there
yeah okay yeah what's your take on this
I we did I just tuned into it so I have
no idea it's been a very sacrificial
game the whole time it feels like it
smells like meat yeah yes should be
something all right
I am I thought that was a very nice game
you played Victor and I have a couple
questions and maybe my naive questions
will help the fans understand where you
were coming from here in this game so
let's pull it up and I assume you so you
played this Queen a4 in that's that's a
very Victor make a left you kind of move
Queen it for I played like this against
him already
okay yeah and I played this with black
and it's it's fine probably some other
position yeah
so we get this stuff and do you think a6
is controversial 6 was new for me yeah
okay so the idea is obviously she wants
to stop queen bee fight right right
but Queen b5 is not that big of a deal
right that's what white usually places
like so they're gonna make you one
little stupid paradox you place a six
and I really like your next move here g4
yeah that's the difference now I can
they could want the troops of foxy eight
square some coverage right so as we
pointed out before tell me if I got this
right that the point was you take yeah
and then rook d6 and if rip d6 you've
got the brutal Queen e8 yeah so he can't
take maybe he can still take on shift
for it right yeah maybe he could just do
it I mean same line but he doesn't take
on these six twice just once right place
knight c6
at least then your rooks will say I have
I'm in right I'm in there yeah
so right this was kind of this was the
passive option okay Queen c2 97 g5
Bishop c6h4 it was just to take some
space in the Kings right no let me just
say this
this amount okay I I was watching a
little bit you were starting to drift in
the little time pressure mm-hmm and I
imagine here it's difficult to know
exactly what to do right yeah yeah well
I decided to wait a little bit because
Blake doesn't have a plan so right so
your next two moves are waiting you know
there's all kinds of things of course
you could have played maybe even 95 and
something yeah I so 95 but they said
even if he plays Bishop f8 and I know
what I'm doing I guess what okay let me
just ask you this my prejudice against
what you did obviously it worked out for
you and everything but my prejudice
against this move was that you were
trading pieces when he was yeah but that
I didn't I didn't think how to make
progress without this move so I have to
trade as a bishops and then at least
they can push my F and D pawns okay so
let me ask a naive question right
something like e for always double ish
because he can play five five nine 96
right right right I don't know if it
works right away because I just take
only 5 and 0 ng it is unprotected but
you can just play like rook a to a8
first maybe and a half so okay so you
just want to take it nice and slow
yeah nice one and here is interesting he
gave you multiple opportunities to play
e4 like a normal player a guy who
doesn't jump out of airplanes would have
just taken on g2 right away
nobody said alright I'll give you a
chance and then he's like okay I'll give
you another chance to play for but maybe
you just said to yourself no I'm a
my choice already I just wanted to bring
my night we had G 2 3 3 so I thought I
better trade bishops easy for me it's
important to cover say five square
because I want to play Knight G 2 is 3
and then F 5 at some point
look at that you held off I still don't
get it Victor okay look yours you're
clearly a better position no you're
better than me at this stuff so tell me
why instead of playing efore now yeah
you instead like took and then play d4
yeah yeah I just wanted to play Knight G
2 is 3 with a bishop on g2 I have to
waste more time ok the position is
already good enough I don't care to keep
so why why do you like it so much then I
don't III I just because then I can play
a 5
ok and he says no you can't yeah he
doesn't do any Knight is really in the
fight yeah alright so 93 yeah I have to
cover a 5 if I don't do it he takes only
foreign place Knight a5 but what's your
evaluation is finished that's what I'm
much better but still I have to be
precise because there are some tricks so
right this piece is terrible this guy is
not doing much
yeah but in order to break through I
have to take on i-5 at some point right
and then he may take with a cheap phone
and he gets h5g 6 squares for his
knights mm-hmm so you hit this one yeah
if I play it takes the 5 right there I
wasn't sure maybe he can even play Queen
f3 was a double attack right now what
kids while you're watching this if you
turn on your computers they probably
wouldn't be playing big mix moves but
what you can learn is he's just saying I
can take my time right leg has no idea
where you didn't have time was on your
clock ok
eh-eh now you qui d3 gonna bring up the
idea of Queen DC what's toe coverage 5
so when I take on a 5 I can play Queen
e2 and coverage 5 right
nice weenie - yeah very important to
keep yeah because they've night Jiggs
and I have age five right or it may be
Bishop g3 first and h5 wasn't sure
because Nigel 6 H 5 he may try knowledge
for probably doesn't work and I guess
the okay so then Bishop d8 and the
bummer for team or I guess is that that
Bishop on a5 it's more active in e7 but
it's not really a star yeah right not
really start so H 5 that's just an
old-school Soviet move just like what
you know I'm certain image yeah it's no
time at all yeah maybe he should have
taken on sister II just I worried of
this night yeah also he's he has a
little less space so just in pretty
durable yeah take the thing but team
word a man who skydives might not want
now it seemed very pleasant for you yeah
and this was a that was cold-blooded
right there yeah but in fact when I
played Queen [ __ ] I wasn't that sure
maybe he can still take on g2 and take
on h5 to give up the d6 pawn and play
Bishop c7 right away aha
so say Queen she - I wasn't sure if I
should take with the knight King maybe
Knight takes to protect I for for yeah
so yeah because if I take with the King
maybe it also works King takes Knight at
age five for up d6 he plays Bishop
system right away no no not in this
position sorry here's a rock on d1 is
protected so first he takes probably and
then plays Bishop seasoned probably
still good for me but Rock takes a six
and then he takes on f4 with something
some complications which probably I
don't like Lee it's very good for is
potential for counter play yeah you're
gonna win this pawn but it's still gonna
be counter play some computer yeah yeah
Robles still in formation
it was funny I predicted this I said to
myself teamers not gonna want to take
you no no yeah I can even take this a
night on she to to protect for us that
was another idea which is also
interested that's more solid yeah okay
he takes on h5 rook takes d6 and then he
plays Bishop season without trade in
hooks because my rock on g1 isn't
protect the other thing I realized is if
he wants to he can play Bishop c7 yes he
can also play like this still worked
yeah III can play when h6 brings the
kink to three bishop g1 and maybe that's
that's just that feels like it's lost
I think if five was probably blunder
already but of course the position is
the skydiver move right there yeah maybe
in 95 e for he sought a I should play
Queen e2 uh-huh
and then he takes the three so Queen e2
it takes dismisses in fact interesting
but I can even take only seven with the
Queen if I want sure was one of the
options if I take with the night maybe
some move like King f7 but I wasn't sure
right because making the Queen is under
attack so that was probably the trick
but first of all I can take on a seven
here with the Queen and they can also
take only seven first in this position
like ninety seven rookie sevens and
Queenie - yeah and then it's much simply
just open exchange so right if he has to
play rookie six well then you're just
ripping it all up yeah and Bishop b5 is
just one of the options Knight f6 also
means a bill
very nice yeah this is like a this is
like an advertisement for playing really
slow we could put this to music takes
check oh yeah and I took with the rock
night X should also win but I didn't
want to let him play Queenie ate and
give some chicks so I just thought this
means on the spot so now I had to
calculate Knight takes rook takes and
then I thought Bishop g8 is probably the
only move to attack my name because h6
is a threat so I thought Bishop g2 is
idea of taking my knight is his only
chance and then I was going to play
Queen d7 probably it works Queen takes
rook takes yeah that's kinda age six is
still sweat in there and I don't know if
he has any defense if this if Bishop
takes up second she takes f6 yeah you
know actually when he played Queen c8 I
was like and I predicted he's gonna do
it and I was like well the problem is
your queen is eventually gonna come in
there like a pinball machine all right
Victor beautiful game I'm happy that you
know the old guys you know got one here
old old old stole time style to it
yeah all right well good luck in the
next round
yeah thanks a lot all right and we're
gonna go to a little commercial break
and then we'll start art we're going to
come back to the games
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
[Music]
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the Blues
what about after the game heading back
to the hotel would be a major error
stead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues complain with us you guys know I
can't play this right st. Loup is always
exploring the question on Twitter from
dem s I should not have pronounced that
that was a bit of a champion for those
of you who are new to chess it might
look like ba3 is an illegal move here
because white masses point to squares
not one but it still is something we
call on per song and you can do that but
you have to do it instantly you can't
wait for a move like let's say clay king
in seven Kingi - and now try because
[Music]
Lawrence hello Lauren yell played four
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which would
disgust the playing during the course of
my stay
yeah he told me this is excellent g5
this was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think we practiced I know
who Lawrence
this is not how chess works certainly
would be much much more fun if chess
actually work like this I don't think it
does well maybe it does
well that's me regretting what I just
said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me and what's worse I
will never hear the end of it my quality
of life has just gone downhill
tremendously because I'm actually
sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
you
[Music]
hello everybody I'm here with Nicholas
Theodore who just won a marvelous game
against my friend GM Eugene peril Stein
I'm gonna forgive him for that because
it was very nice but before we jumped to
his game I want to look at a game in
progress with Jeffrey playing saucy and
some amazing stuff has gone down him
when we left we were looking at this
position Sasi has just sacked the pawn
with b5 a little bit in desperation but
with a very nice idea of playing c4 and
watch how Jeffrey's responds he says
okay I'll give you that exchange and
you're gonna give me this night on c4
ends big-time pressure this is all
happening rook b8 Bishop e5 takes takes
Queen b7 and look at this nice move b6
very tough to deal with and on his 40th
move sassy took Queen d5 so a very
unbalanced position where obviously we
have night against rook in the past beep
on blacks King is obviously exposed and
I thought I'd use this opportunity to
ask Nikolas just what is intuitive
assessment of this position was here I
don't know exactly but it looks quite
complicated and double-edged I don't
know what is going to help another 97 ok
yes let's let's take a look so 97 rook
e8 and now white can either go Knight f6
or queen b5 I guess probably Queen b5
unless black has a way out looks it
looks hard to deal with because b7 b8 is
on the agenda yeah so 97 yeah I guess
that's our big candidate
I don't I don't see anything else for
white right if f4 is just gonna take our
pawn Abby says yeah I think the cost
aeroplane 97 yeah it's it looks vicious
it looks vicious alright so we'll come
back to this game later but let's check
in with your game where you played I
think I guess I would call this very
some very intuitive attacking chest you
I assumed you knew that you'd what
Eugene was gonna play cuz he always does
the same thing yeah he's been doing this
for a long time and I saw you you
obviously saw that coming because you'd
played that before prepare a five-course
enjoy and I knew you I knew that was
coming because with big Mick you like to
put your knight on c5 a knight on e5
yeah that's one of your favorites their
signature move so 96a for Queen b6 a5
Queen b6 96 Queen a6 very tough position
at first time I said I thought Eugene
was fine here and maybe he is because
his position looks solid but obviously
it's his queen on a6 that's a problem
piece because in some lighting it can
easily get attacked by Bishop f4 is if
f1 even that one from me two moves so I
don't know I think some players have
tried arrow could do it in this position
so you already knew this but you gotta
listen advance okay yeah I don't think
he had he knew about this position in
advance
yeah okay so rookie one this is tell me
when your prep ended how about that I
should have five I hadn't looked at
there is more oh you hadn't looked okay
yeah night so 95 very double-edged right
because now the d4 pawn is gonna be a
week and in the commentary I said that
you have a problem on the D file and he
has a problem with the Queen yes I want
to play me for right allows me to do so
so 97 I think it's still okay for him he
for snip ef5 rook 88 and this is a tense
position you took in why can't my friend
Eugene peril Stein just take back on g6
oh yeah we had a brief look at this game
with Eugene I thought it finished and we
thought that 866 would have been better
right right
because one of the things I really
admire about what comes next that what
you did is it feels like you sense now
that the light squares were especially
weak on the Kings side and you were just
like I'm the go for it I'm critical of
Eugene c5 as well it feels like he's
helping you open the position especially
the bishop on g2 a little bit I'm saying
to play Bishop f1 although it's not so
easy for a block to come up with a plan
all right
but worst case scenario like let's just
say it was your move here and you play
[ __ ] before he can still play b5
the pawns are going to be very weak
after every five right on that green
side okay so here we go and I'm gonna
I'm gonna be criticizing a gene for this
a little while he starts grubbin but it
starts being a pawn grumper he's been
listening to yasser Sarah want too much
and it Grubbs another font and I really
like your next move here h4 no I'm just
gonna guess you tell me if I'm wrong but
this is mostly just intuitive right
you're not I mean the night on the 66
fight anything awkwardly placed so I
mean his queen is also ran over queen
side away from the defense so it makes
sense to just a talk well just for the
fans here let's look at this because I
think most mortals would have sniped on
b7 why did you take the pot instead
playdates for I think I would like him
to play rook b8 huh and then the rook
yeah and then there's chances of
survival uh-huh okay yeah no I think h4
s I mean mostly most people see that
part of b7 they take it but h4 is nice
and then not only that but once the
knight moves then when you take on b7
the pawn at a 7 which leads I guess that
helps explain Bishop f6 his next move he
wants to protect e7 is ready
so H 595
Bishop f4 Knight c4 and here's about
where it's gonna get spicy here rook b7
now I'm gonna guess that Eugene's
original intention was 96
I could assume so I can stay play look
like c7 oh that was you know chest fans
were dealing with the madman but some an
old guy would just take and say I have
the light squares and try to win that
way but no Brooke take C seven yeah why
not it's also interesting to take with
the other group because you're I think
because that they can be seven because
if she takes the ricany seven I can play
Quincy for Jack let's take a look here
check and this will be fired
he said oh man oh man that's pretty good
if Knight f7 chess fans the Bishop f6 is
the end of the world
very nice yeah so if I've already felt a
little bit like a desperation move which
must have I mean that's gonna get really
interesting
tell us about how you came up with
Bishop g4 because there were you could
do other things
I think mr. Bates seeks looks like the
most logical move that's what a normal
person would plan but your move I mean
yeah that's that's the dream right there
yeah so I mean it has to be inspired
with just like well the night the lights
where's our there so let's go after I
guess right yes because aged seven
ponies by the way now let's just see if
I was right I was thinking all right if
he takes the bishop then is it okay to
immigrate through yeah Queen a to check
screens across yes Bishop g7 and not
green enough five Queen f5 right and the
the horrible thing here is that rook e8
as we said that loses the Queen f7 let
me just and then if Queen a1 is it rook
b1 I think I hope I gotta go think it's
two and not GT you wanna 82
yeah okay I guess this is not going to
work but I was thinking maybe I'll live
this way I can take enough seven and
then play it six others my invention
fufufu yeah doesn't look nice
what's it look nice I mean okay just
just to play it out takes which way do
you want I think and then it's ripped g8
my only chance I know bring my three to
five very nice yeah beautiful
okay so Eugene played 96 and now really
everything is hanging everything is like
and you play the very nice Bishop b1 and
yeah we analyze this in the broadcast as
well taking on f4 I guess either one
Queen d3 right or Queen c2 in my
previous game where a lot of pieces were
finding right well you clearly enjoy it
did you enjoy this kind of thing so he
comes in to stop you from doing the
Queen c2 and you retreat the roof so
that's one piece that's not hanging and
then you said you know what I have to
have some kind of sacrificial things so
I'll play rook me fine I didn't want to
allow him to consolidate right okay and
he snips I thought I'm sure you have
something against so I I thought f6
wasn't gonna be his intention I wasn't
sure about to play after I've six but I
think I can try rook c3
and I don't know something like that I'm
no Queen victory
nice oh yeah so if rook f7 your Bishop
f6 probably probably right it's it's
still pretty hairy though isn't it yeah
and I guess rook d7 then Bishop d6 yeah
right okay I'm just gonna believe you
I'm gonna believe you on that one f e8
and here's a nice one Bishop f6 maybe
you were inspired by Van Voorhis game I
played Bishop f6 against ya
it's very uncomfortable and like that
here you probably felt you were just
winning right oh I wasn't doing that but
like I was waiting so he tried to trade
off your evil rook and you said no
Bishop d3 that's another cruel move so
let's just show if Queen takes b3
there's the terrible queen g4 it was the
intention and so Eugene says I'm gonna
keep going over here by the way I just
want to say one thing that I admire
about Nicholas's instincts about this
whole Bishop before thing is the problem
defensively is the Queen is being
separated from her man that's the main
problem yeah the main problem Queen d2
simple threat Queen g5 check to the
miserable King I don't care
rook b3 oh man this is terrible very
nice game okay this is gonna be in your
best games collection yeah that's a real
beauty well thank you for sharing the
game I wish you good luck the rest the
tournament thank you it was my pleasure
alright so let's continue looking at
Jeffrey's game really an interesting
situation nicholas correctly predicted
Knight d7 and then rook a8 and we had
the the bailout kind of looking thing
with Knight of six this would look like
much and Geoffrey played what we thought
he was going to do with Queen b5 so what
is the problem
b7 b8 is
and black needs some kind of counter
play before the hammer Falls check
happened King H 2 and now saucy is
asking himself a very simple and
important question is there some way
that I can create counter play let's
note it's not only the knight touching
b8 that's useful it's not only the
knight touching f6 it's useful forking
the king and queen but it's a very big
deal that he stopped the stopping queen
'if I've check which would not only
create some counter play but also touch
the b8 square which be useful in
defending this whole thing my sense is
that this is now lost saucy is thinking
about it it's hard it's hard to okay
here's a thought well for example you
cannot play rook a to with the hope that
b7 rook F 2 creates counter play because
unfortunately Knight f6 is going to
happen to you that's unfortunate
ok so you gotta do something either the
queen or the king again though b7 is
coming so let's imagine what would
happen if Queen b7 was played now by
saucy maybe some dreams of holding on
here but I'm gonna guess this is
probably not gonna work
some kind of queen bee to Knight f6
thing oh man you can pick your order
there which one you ever want to be more
accurate about but that looks absolutely
devastating you might even start off
with Knight f8 check first but Queen B -
that's the real deal right there
dang chess fans let's review this for
just a second this was pretty impressive
Knight b6 it looks like saucy in time
pressure is getting some kind of counter
play boom the exchange sacrifice
the night goes where it wants to go the
bishop is freed and look at that night
incredible in this position if we talk
to Jeffrey after the game we might
discover that black had something else
but queen bee 7 is a natural move and
time pressure b6 is beautiful absolutely
beautiful move you can't really take on
B 6 because Queen d7 is some kind of
mate
well yeah maid is going to follow and
Queen d5 was played 97 and it's a big
question to me how much of this Jeffry
saw when he played rugby 6 but rook b6
you know such a nice exchange sacrifice
intuitive leading to a situation like
this where we're believing in the B
point also we're believing that there's
no counter play there have been a couple
moves and rook a to was played which
wait a second is that right let me get
this right that's not right so
Queen d6 was playing f4 we d1 alright so
there we have it that's the attempted
counter play to at the very least start
bouncing around in here with G 1 and e1
Knight f6 and now what should thought
see play it looks like he has to play
King g7 because King h8 is gonna fall to
Queen eh so let's look King g7 and we
need a good move here
I'm gonna get saucy is simply away from
the board
that's a king's ease that it looks like
the only move
what well just yet I'm happy to be back
it's been a while yes Ben Simon and
Jesse cry here about to come to the
conclusion of our show but is it
possible to take a look at the at the
actual physical board of Geoffrey Zhang
and sassy just to see yeah yeah yeah
maybe what the players are thinking
right now
yeah let's get some body language it's
so hard to calculate these positions and
there they are deep and thought and King
g7 is on the board it's not now it's
showing up so King g7 is there and here
he comes he has a plan already Knight to
d5 do I see that right Knight to d5 oh
all right so let's talk about what's
going on first of all taking the night
looks like it's not gonna work because
of b7 Y wins well it might not be
totally over like let's let's check this
because this will be important for the
other variations Queen check
check and here's the business we're
gonna play King f3 and it's because my
queen can come back that's why we're
where there's no perpetual if Queen d1
we have Queen e2 and I have a feeling
we're gonna see that escape pattern in
the other variations that we're gonna
look at here
so if Queen g1 King g3 Queen e1 King f3
again no escape let's say something else
kind of obvious a way to sing music I
might have blown it in that position by
the way we need Queen g3 there's no
check on e3 because of our beautiful
night however let's go through that
another variation maybe I missed
something
b7 Queen d1 Queen no we can't do this
isn't gonna work this is gonna be this
is gonna be a draw so in fact there
might even be some grief for us though
there might be a different intention
after Queen d5 oh I got it look at that
Queen B - hello oh man
Queen B - I'm sorry I'm sorry it had to
end this way and I think that is just
over for example King f7 Queen a1 and
Queen a7 fold by b7 b8 is gonna be on
the table very nice move with 95
and sauce he's thinking about it it's
that's a cold shower of a move right
there beautiful game Queens every is
bringing it queen g1 played and King g3
so without taking the night right yeah
now he's going for the check on the eat
one and let's see if I'm right at f3 oh
it's a draw
oh they had there was something wrong
with King f3 Oh Jesse I'm glancing over
now that the game is over and yeah they
said this has been for a while now with
best play a draw because of Queen f1
it'd be interesting to see it I guess it
wasn't thinking here unfortunately we
don't we do not have time for a third
interview today
okay we can ask him tomorrow yeah we
have a future hey take us back a little
bit but yes this looks this looks like
maybe this isn't enough for what because
the black king is coming over oh man but
bummer because that was a beaut I love
that game with Rick a6 well this has
been a very entertaining day
yeah if we've seen both of the top
leaders have their perfect scores
tarnished a little bit yeah it still
it's anybody's chess tournament we still
have another week of play remember seven
more rounds in this double well it's a
single round-robin but two fields two
round-robin event so and I'll tell
everybody the reason it was so exciting
today was because Bobby's nose and
moustache was my mouse pad
what it's working out Hey only two days
left two days whether they have the
opening ceremony is real and the hour
today and chess coverage begins in just
two days hear from the st. Louis Chess
Club will be giving you the breakdown
with Jenn Yassir and Maurice
it all begins in two days on November
9th and you can catch it all right here
at us chess champs calm they'll also be
doing coverage of the Women's World
Championship they'll be in the round of
16
the a-team will be covering this
bringing it to you it's gonna be a lot
of fun us chess champs calm remember
right after that and actually at the
same time the st. Louis Invitational the
norm tournaments it's gonna be crazy
this is how we end the year and then in
December the London final of the grand
chess
tour can you handle this much chess
goodness this is gonna be amazing grand
chests org for that last event and we'll
see if Fabiano Carolina can win the
world championship win the London chess
classic win the grand chest or wow what
a year but will will see things will
become clear in just two days time this
event was put was produced by the
world's greatest production B team Tammy
Hyde is the streamer Isaac's France is
the audio and graphics man Danny Machuca
is our technical director at big news
this weekend you will all see the return
of the one and only Jonathan shruts as
the host you'll be joined by a person
that the fans out there have been asking
for for quite a bit is a live streaming
debut here at the Chess Club he'll be
hosting on Saturday and Sunday for round
six and seven so we're proud to tell you
that
so for grandmaster and residents jessie
cry my name is Ben Simon we'll see you
tomorrow at 3:30 p.m. Central right here
at u.s. chess chips calm so long from
the Show Me State
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you